all right so let's sort of close the
loop on our coverage of the matt gates
situation i told you uh last segment
that uh donald trump had to be talked
out of publicly defending
matt gates because the believed
allegations against him are so
serious now in the next segment you will
see that matt gates is still claiming
that he has support from donald trump
but breaking this morning a report from
cnn
that matt gates tried to meet with
donald trump and was denied
such a meeting it seems as though donald
trump has been
thoroughly convinced by his uh aides and
staffers that uh matt gates is
completely toxic right now and actually
this fits very much
within what we know about donald trump
and i'll i'll get into that in a moment
the report from cnn is that congressman
matt gates
facing a federal investigation into sex
trafficking allegations
recently was denied a meeting that he
tried to get with donald trump at
trump's mar-a-lago
estate as trump and allies continue to
distance
from the florida congressman two people
familiar
with the matter say that uh gates
tried to schedule a visit with donald
trump after it was revealed that he was
being investigated
but the request was rejected by aides
close to donald trump who as i mentioned
to you in the previous segment are
telling trump
don't stick your neck out for this guy
don't defend
matt gates harlan hill
who is a spokesman for gates is denying
it and saying
no such meeting was requested and that
actually
gates was welcomed to trump doral this
weekend
and didn't try to meet with donald trump
now
my instinct is that this is of course if
you are
if you're matt gates you request the
meeting
through staff and if it's rejected the
staff
simply deny having requested it and if
you're matt gates
you can accurately say i never requested
anything
so if you say well how do i adjudicate
the differences between the claims that
are being made
it's it's quite obvious to me that uh
the this is exactly what
the way it would work if indeed matt
gates quietly tried to get the meeting
and it was
rejected cnn writes that the
interference by trump's aides
signals that gates is increasingly
isolated
as he weathers a potentially career
ending scandal
just months after he offered to leave
his job
to join trump's impeachment defense team
comedically
gates joining the impeachment defense
team may have been more
substantive as far as you know like
saturday night live writers are
concerned
but this may actually be a much more
interesting sort of going down
in flames for matt gates now you'll also
remember
that last week it was revealed and
reported that matt gates tried to get a
blanket pre-emptive pardon from donald
trump
at the end of donald trump's presidency
that has also been denied by donald
trump trump claiming
gates did not ask me for a pardon again
with all of these things
it's possible that gates staffers went
to trump staffers and said would this
work
trump staffers would have said he's not
going to do that and as far as trump
knows
it was never an official request and so
nobody's really lying
but the spirit of this is that gates did
want
the pardon that's often you know in
political speak
the way this is all orchestrated is to
have that plausible deniability trump
can say
i was never asked to pardon him and that
can be true
while it can also be true that gates
directed staff
to feel out trump staff as to whether
it's something that
might be possible um now
the the other kind of question about the
meeting being denied between gates and
trump
is that gates was at this event in
florida
and although he didn't meet privately
with trump
you would think that that has some
meaning that he was still sort of
allowed
to participate at the other on the other
end
what can trump really even do for gates
at this point i mean it seems that at
this point the story is so out of the
bag
either republicans big picture are just
going to start ignoring it
and matt gates will be able to survive
this and won't have to resign
or gates is basically going to be done
for but beyond just repeating the same
lies
that gates is telling i don't really
know what trump can do for gates at this
point in time
when trump was president lying about
himself to some degree worked in another
sense it didn't because trump lost
and he lost the house for republicans
and he lost the senate but it at least
kept
trump afloat amid some scandals
trump as a former president telling lies
in defense of matt gates
it's not really clear to me that it
would do very much now one last thought
on this before we move on to what matt
gates is actually saying about all of
these things
um loyalty is a one-way street
with donald trump matt gates was
completely loyal to a sort of disgusting
sycophantic level
uh during trump's presidency but gates
is no longer
useful to donald trump once you're no
longer useful to trump or you have your
own problems
trump tosses you aside like he's done to
so many people in his life eventually
it's always just a matter of time so
that's the latest from trump
let's now look at some of the very
strange things that matt gates said